i still work monday through friday nine
to five even though
i quit my monday through friday nine to
five job
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
scott how do you like living in san
diego three months in sunny
it's very sunny
[Music]
good morning everybody it's wednesday
and it's
such a hot day already it's like 80
degrees outside and it's only 8 30 a.m
i wanted to address all of the hair
comments that i get in my videos
i've been getting them very steadily and
there's always comments about it
my hair is is it's like its own persona
i feel like it's got its own personality
its own character
on my channel at this point and some of
y'all are interested in how i take care
of it so i thought i'd show you like the
things that i use i guess
because maybe you're interested if not
fast forward to this time stamp below um
but basically
i used to use pantene pro v and then i
was like
i want to treat myself i'm going to
actually take care of my hair and see
what the difference of like a japanese
shampoo could do because i was like
hey i have japanese hair maybe i should
use japanese shampoo
so i've been using these kind of like
bagged shampoo and conditioners i use
both
right now i'm using the ichikami uh
shampoo and conditioner set
i like that they come in bags because
then i can put them in these reusable
bottles that i have so that i don't
always have to throw bottles away
i used to use like the naive one for a
while which i also really liked but
really i just liked how japanese
shampoo and conditioners smell and it
kind of started from there
but i think that's really my secret like
i let it air dry
overnight i rarely blow dry it uh when i
do blue dried it's extra
voluminous and i use a heat protectant
for my hair when i
when i do use a blow dryer i also wash
my hair every other day
because then otherwise my hair and my
scalp will dry out on the days that i
don't wash my hair sometimes i use
dry shampoo but recently my hair hasn't
been very
oily so i don't i just like brush my
hair the next day and that's it
other than that i just have like a lot
of hair it's very
thick the strands are also very
like thick too yeah i don't do anything
to my hair i don't dye it i don't permit
i just wash it with the stuff with good
stuff and that's kind of it
i think i have my mom to thank for my
hair because
she has also like this exact same hair
that's that's how i have good hair
i guess is this the kind of stuff you
put in a vlog i think so
that's why i'm doing it but yeah
japanese shampoo
that's where it's at my hair is up now
because it's
just so hot and i need it out of the way
but i wanted to take a moment and say
thank you to the sponsor of today's
video boxu
boxing offers a gourmet journey through
japan with a different box every single
month
i'm so excited to be working with boxes
again thanks to you all for using the
link last time because they
sent me snacks from the motherland
they're the only japanese snack box that
partners with over a hundred
japanese family-owned snack makers and
delivers them
in a monthly box right to your door each
box comes with 20 to 25
snacks candies and tea pairings
that are all centered around a specific
theme every month
when you order your first box you're
going to get the seasons of japan bok su
you're going to get a lot of different
snacks from all different seasons from
all across japan i had that one it was
so
good i really enjoyed it they provide
free shipping from japan to over 40
countries which is great because it's a
lot cheaper than going to japan
especially during copa times and getting
those snacks and bringing them back when
i do go to japan i usually get like a
haul of snacks to bring back to enjoy
but usually it's a snapshot of the
season that i'm in because boxy sends a
box every month their stuff is very
seasonal which is really great because
like this month's box
is autumn harvest and it has things like
sweet potato
chestnut pie apple madeleines
like a little hojicha cake for fall this
also looks super good too
man i can't wait to eat these look at
this look at how good that looks like oh
my goodness
so because they're a sponsor of this
video get 10 off your very own box sue
for a savings of up to 44 by using the
code mayuko 10 or the link in the
description box down below seriously
y'all if you use the link and you order
a boxy then i get to keep working with
them and i really like working with them
so help me out support this channel and
give some snacks delivered to your door
thank you boxy for sponsoring and i hope
you all enjoy
scott what are we making spaghett forget
look at how long your hair is
my hair is pretty good so long we're
making spaghetti
out of my hair gross we're gonna we're
gonna make roy choi's
recipe that we saw in the chef show
and uh it's gonna take a little bit and
right now everything's going or it's in
the works
and i think i'm gonna make my apple
cider that uh i've been
i made once last week and i'm gonna make
it again because i drink it so fast
she did i drink one cup of it
really yeah
[Music]
oh the house is smelling divine
also don't judge me for my peeling
technique i could
use a knife and do it all but it makes
my hand cramped so i'm just using one of
these
because i've got a lot of apples to do
honestly things have been a little bit
stressful for me lately mostly just
because i have a lot of like
deadlines to meet and stuff which is a
good thing i'm
like ever since kind of committing and
going on this like
full-time creator career uh early this
year things are going really well
and a lot of it is really thanks to you
all for like watching my videos and
everything
i think it's true for any business that
you create
in your first year you just gotta hustle
and that's just like what it means to
create a new company
it's taking a lot of work honestly in
some ways it's more demanding than being
a software engineer in silicon valley
but
i do really enjoy the freedom that i get
of being able to work on what i want
make
my own decisions and stuff and really
just like just take
control of my career i guess more than i
was before
i realized recently because like last
week specifically i was just like
super stressed out um just because i had
so many different things to do
and it felt like the days weren't long
enough and everything
but i realized like i still work nine to
five i still work
monday through friday nine to five even
though
i quit my monday through friday nine to
five job
to do this and i thought it was really
interesting
that that happened because i don't have
to work monday through friday nine to
five
i was like why do i work these like
hours
that i was trying to escape from to
begin with when i say that i love the
flexibility
of working for myself being able to set
my own hours is one part of it right
like i don't think i fully shed
my like silicon valley working as a
software engineer
skin i guess there's a big part of me
that's still just like i have to be
doing
the most impactful work that people
needed yesterday and therefore
i'm gonna work hard and like i do work
hard and
i also try to set boundaries for myself
so i've figured out that like i will
work
nine to five but then after five o'clock
or six o'clock
i'm not gonna do any work and that has
helped me to keep some semblance of a
work-life balance
especially last week when i was just
having a lot of trouble
working between the hours of nine to
five i was talking to my therapist where
i was just like
i've just been having really big issues
with motivation and it's just really
hard to get things done and she's like
well honey
why are you working nine to five you
don't have to right in some ways because
a lot of things for me they're just very
unknown like i've never
had a time like this where i really
don't know what i'm gonna be doing
five years from now because there isn't
like a set
path for me and i have to do it all
myself
i think the way that i've coped with
everything instead is just to like
take control of everything and try to
hold on for dear life
to some semblance of control of my life
really
i don't know i know that it's a tendency
of mine to
take control in places where i don't
have control because that's the way that
i
like deal with ambiguity that's the way
that i feel safe
but in reality it's like the best things
happen when you let go of that control
and you just let yourself live a little
and just like see what happens
in times like this where just everything
in the world is so crazy
any change that you bring forward in
your life that is really different from
what it's used to
means that it does require that much
more energy
in order to get that thing done so i
think i had this unrealistic expectation
of myself to be like oh
i'm fine because i've done this amount
of work before
for something completely different but
it'll be okay i fully expect myself
to work monday through friday nine to
five like i've always done
and perform an output in the same way in
reality that's not
realistic because my brain is working in
ways that
has never worked that it's never worked
before and i am experiencing
so much change there's been a lot of
change for me in 2020
and so my body does need that much more
energy
in order to process and move through
everything that's going on
i really shouldn't cheat myself of the
rest that i need
the food that i eat also the grounding
that i need to do
i don't know i think things like making
pasta from scratch
making apple juice is how i ground
myself basically
amidst everything that's going on both
in the world
and then also with me my birthday is
also this month
and so i think i'm just feeling a little
bit pondery
looking back on the last year and seeing
just how it's all gone and
you know just marveling at how much i've
changed but also
still feeling a little bit underwater as
usual for what i
should be doing or what i could be doing
but i think in the last year i have
learned a lot
how to be kind to yourself and how to
set boundaries
and challenging expectations that i have
of myself
and seeing what i can replace with that
you know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
all done homemade apple juice
let's try it
oh that's really good it's better than i
made it last week to be honest
[Music]
so
[Music]
you